And she's carrying something.
It's not uncommon for a film to reveal
its main theme and the opening scene of
its story and Esu.
Grab the audience's attention and give
them a taste of what's to come,
not unlike to ferry essay that I'm
reading to you right now or really any
other medium to tries to effectively
convey a message.
American sniper,
as you can see here is no exception to
this navy seal.
Chris Kyle is laying on a rooftop in war
torn Fallujah.
His rifle aimed at a mother and her son
away for Clint Eastwood to point us to
his films,
main theme family or rather the tragic
destruction of family through war.
However,
it seems that this message didn't really
get you on to a number of high profile
audiences.
Most notable or tweets from the likes of
Seth Rogan,
who compared to films who to throw Nazi
propaganda movie shown and the third act
of inglorious bastards.
Then there is Michael Moore staying at
all snipers are cowards.
No on Chomsky weighing in on what he
states is a testament of support of
everything that's wrong with American
foreign policy.
Documentary director Robert Greenwald,
doing roughly the same thing on MSNBC
and finally former presidential
candidate Howard Dean speaking his mind
on real time with Bill Maher.
I bet you if you looked at a cross
section of the tea party and people
would go to see this movie,
there's a lot of intersection I could go
on for a while,
but I think you get the point.
A lot of high profile partisan liberal
viewers did not enjoy what they
interpreted to be blatantly pro war
propaganda movie.
The movie made by a man whose personal
politics already seems to run counter to
dos who stand against the film.
When somebody does not do the job,
we've got to let them go
and then he would have therefore
naturally and consciously made a movie
that shows audiences each simplistic and
glorified version of the war were just
odd to say the least.
This that would be completely out of
character for clinic sweet and director
who has a record of making nuanced and
often openminded films.
The glamorizing negritude is killing in
western movies addressing gender and
class issues for women in sports.
You minimizing Japanese soldiers during
the Second World War.
Tackling the corrupt criminal justice
system of the early 20th century and
being criticized by some conservatives
for gramitizing to homosexual private
life of FBI director,
Edgar Hoover,
not you accurately point out the true
message of American sniper.
We can make use of literary theorist
Kenneth Burke's cluster analysis method,
which attempts to seek out the film's
most important recurring terms with the
positive god term on the one hand and a
counter acting devil term on the other
in between floats,
subordinate terms that align with either
of the main terms,
but that can change their value as the
story progresses.
But before we get into any of that,
let's start by taking a closer look at
our gods term.
In order to truly understand the
character of Chris Kyle and why he does
what he does,
we first need to examine how his value
system works.
Traveling back to is you.
If we can observe how is strict
upbringing in a highly conservative
household late the foundations for the
man.
He would later from his father stoic
sheepdog philosophy of protecting the
defense lists from all this evil in the
world.
Two sermons about God's plan for his
believers,
yet unknown path to glory.
And lastly a lesson in perseverance.
Get back here.
You don't ever leave your rifle in the
dirt.
Yes sir.
All these teachings work for her to
concept with family,
to protect it from danger,
to believe in God's plan for his glory
and to never abandoned one's duty
towards it.
It's this value system to cal carries
with them into adulthood and that after
perhaps having laid dormant for some
time miss reawakened by the terrorist
attacks on the American embassies,
cows,
wards and emotional reaction indicating
that his notion of family has extended
into the nation as family and attack on
the nation is indirectly and attack on
his own family,
which pushes him into joining the navy
seals who like many other military units
actively try to form a tight knit group
of non quitters
for the faint of heart there they wash
out the quit on my most men don't quit,
so Chris,
despite has apparent old age,
stays faithful to his beliefs and
doesn't quit and this other newly
perceived family.
Another instance where Chris's values
influence events is when he manages to
grab the interest of his future wife
Taya after he denounced as a fellow seal
for cheating and quitting on his
marriage.
Kristen say a shared love for family.
You make sure subsequent relationship
grow and things seem to be shaping up to
cal's divine plan for awhile until one
fateful September morning,
no
wars devil term that slowly starts to
take control over at Kyle's family
values.
The first value that's bootsy that's
asked is a sheepdog notion of protecting
family,
which as we've seen consists of three
layers.
His family at home is military family
and his country.
As Cruz is deployed to Iraq,
we see him excelling in his role on the
battlefield as an overwatch sniper,
keeping the evils of war from his
military family,
as well as keeping it as far away as
possible from his own direct family.
The call home was supposed to go,
however,
he slowly finds out that it's impossible
to do either of these things because
regardless of his extra tease as a
sniper,
he's proven to be unable to protect
every single marine under his watch.
And he also has to live with the fact
that in order to protect his family,
he's forced to destroy another.
And even though he does manage to
protect countless of troops from
physical harm,
he can't shield them from the mental
harm.
The war inevitably causes them as is
exemplified when Chris runs into his
little brother who is about to return
home from the war,
just tired man
cows building frustration over his
inability to protect everyone is when he
witnesses to depths of an Iraqi family.
He vouched to protect after having
extracted vital information from them
and thereby consciously having involved
them into the war.
His first deployment ends those with the
notion that war and protecting food war
inevitably makes collateral damage of
family,
which we can see even more clearly is
cal returns home with his feelings of
frustration and guilt gone on resolve
that quickly becomes clear that far from
having left the war behind Chris has
brought it home in the form of mental
trauma is developing ptsd causes him to
become increasingly disconnected from
his family life.
Having become absent minded,
he constantly slips back to the evils of
the war,
the death of the rocky family.
Perhaps the perfect metaphor for Chris's
inability to keep war and family
separate is when he's watching American
troops getting shot by his rival sniper
while sitting next to at Christmas tree,
the epitome of everything.
Family,
God and peace,
still unwilling to talk about the war.
Chrysalis does unwittingly destroying
his own family.
His tie tries to tell him that Chris
talk about it.
You're not protecting me by not talking
about,
but in Kyle's mind,
protecting through wars,
the only way of protecting both his
direct family as well as his other
families.
Yeah,
not about them.
It's about us.
For Chris quitting the war would mean
quitting on the navy seals or his family
in Iraq,
which is not something has value system
allows him to do and it's why we see him
returning again and again and again.
This no quitting mentality is supported
by his confidence and finding glory in
God's divine plan as he carries with him
Miss Old Bible wherever he goes and he
continuously,
it's sure as tie that you to let him
leave,
right.
What do you,
it's all part of the plan for Chris.
His bath to glory is in a self perceived
crusade against the forces of evil in
Iraq,
which seems to be why he's sporting a
crusader cross to to you,
and why he believes in the righteousness
of the u s presence.
There we're singing God's blessing and
Glory Dafur become associated with war,
it and family.
However,
cal's never ending.
Crusade becomes increasingly reckless
and vengeful over time as he sets out on
a personal mission to find and kill the
people responsible for killing his
fellow soldiers and Iraqi family does.
Transformation can be seen in seals
adopting to punish her logo.
Hey,
marvel,
anti hero who will do anything to get
revenge against the people who killed
his family,
but it's also noticeable in cals
behavior at home where he's now
completely disconnected from his family
leading to tie,
giving him an ultimatum.
If you leave again,
the puppy here when you get back,
not only does cal's plan and obsession
almost destroy what he holds most dear.
It also comes at a cost of two of his
friends,
one of them whose best friend Mark Lee.
It would be preacher turned.
Soldier was slowly becoming
disillusioned by the war and Carl's
dogmatic interpretation of God's blend
for glory.
This is shown through to strongly worded
anti war letter.
He leaves behind my question.
Yeah,
it's one that's glory fade away and
become a rock look.
Oh,
and then just to tie it means by which
consumes what completely.
It's a message of the glorification that
only really hits cow when he's finally
got the chance to take up.
Mustafa you sear in sniper that started
his crusade against orders to stand
down.
Chris chooses to pull the trigger
instead to protect his fellow soldiers,
to show his no quitter mentality and
most of all to finally find catharsis in
his crusade or Ms Bland for glory.
As we staff our false.
However,
there's no great celebration.
No Real Catharsis for Chris as his
friends speaks.
Two words,
mission accomplished,
perhaps referring to George W.
Bush infamous speech after the initial
vision of Iraq had ended.
Of course,
the war was far from over.
At that point,
there was no real nuance spot out plan
for postwar,
our rack giving,
but the false sense of catharsis.
Something similar happens after kyle
takes that shot.
Their position now exposed,
Kyle's team is quickly surrounded by and
surgeons as they face certain death,
you realize is that his crusade will
ultimately be the end of him and his
family.
As he finally decides it's time to go
home.
Oh,
I'm ready.
I'm ready to go home.
By sheer luck,
the team manages to escape then surgeons
for sand storm.
A perfect metaphor for the fog of war,
perhaps signifying Chris struggling with
his internal moral consciousness,
his struggle between family and war,
and it's here where he visually quits on
both the war and dogmatism of his
father's upbringing by leaving his rifle
in the dirt.
However,
even after having,
via aligned with his family and taking
up a healthier sheepdog role by helping
disabled and traumatized veterans deal
with their experiences,
Chris too,
we would ultimately become a victim of
the war.
So I would argue that far from being a
pro war pro neoconservative propaganda
movie,
American sniper can much more accurately
be described as an anti war movie.
The pay thing.
It's destructive nature towards family,
whether it'd be to cal family,
to navy seal brotherhood,
or even the family.
You'll rival sniper.
Mustafa more always in fates the home
and corrupts and destroys it from event
director Clint Eastwood made a film
condemning the war,
not the warrior,
and criticizing the neoconservative
Baltic step resorted to it.
American sniper is not a direct
adaptation of Chris Gal's life and it
isn't meant to be.
These would seem serve roughly adapted a
story to make you broader statement to
make a film that respects and puts
emphasis on its veterans.
One that helps us understand their
experience and one that asks us not to
forget their struggle in the words of
Bradley Cooper,
for me and for Clinton,
this movie was always a character study
about what the plate is for a soldier.
If it's not this movie,
I hope to God another move he will come
out where it will shed light on the fact
of what service men and women have to go
through and that we need to pay
attention to her.
Yvette's it doesn't go any further than
that.
It's not a political discussion about
war even.
It's a discussion about the reality and
the reality is that people were coming
home.
We have to take care of them.
All right.
Thank you all so much for watching and
seeing how much hate American sniper
received.
They just had to express my views of the
movie.
So,
um,
I hope this,
this video clear things up a little bit.
Uh,
I want to thank Danielle Key Mirman for
his thesis on partisan reception of
American sniper,
which was a big influence for this
video,
uh,
Dell's extensively into how and why
political audiences came to such a
widely different interpretation of the
film.
Lastly,
if you want to help us out and sustain
this channel,
hop on over to Patriot or a paypal a
while you can leave as a dollar.
Anyways,
thank you all again for watching happy
4th of July to our American viewers and
I hope to see you all the next one.